hi
that's loud
welcome to the last session of the day
normally i love to take questions during
my talks but if i can't hear you it's
because i've been like partially deaf
for the past few weeks
it's not that i'm ignoring you
at least that's what i've been saying at
home
it's true so we're gonna be talking
about some features from c sharp eight 9
10 11 12 and onwards
there's a lot happening in c sharp as a
programming language
and we're going to go back a little bit
and talk about some of the features that
have been added the past few years and
if you were at my session in porto i
believe two and a half three years ago
there's been a lot of changes in the
language
before we get to that my name is philip
ekberg
i do a lot of talks on c-sharp i have a
few courses on pluralsight on different
types of
c-sharp subjects
if you do have any questions that arise
after this feel free to ping me on
twitter send me an email my book is free
to download as well if you like to dig
into that
so enough about me let's talk about
c-sharp
this here is a map over the features
that have been added in c-sharp over the
years there's quite a lot of language
features
but if you look at the fundamental
building blocks you don't need much you
just need a couple of ifs and elses and
switches and all of that to make a nice
program but what all these language
features allow you to do is to express
yourself in different ways to better
build software that hopefully doesn't
crash
and hopefully it's easier for other
developers to understand as well
one example of that is both the generics
and the async and away keywords
both of these language features were in
its way kind of fundamentally changing
the way that we look at approaching
those different problems
generics change the way that we work
with collections and async in a way
change the way that we work with streams
of data or data that's retrieved
asynchronously
and the aim here is to
get language features into the language
that always do this that always change
the way that we want to approach
problems that might have previously been
hard to express
and we're going to look through a lot of
the features that have been added but
also look at what's coming in c sharp
11.
what's pretty cool with c sharp and vbs
programming languages nf sharp as well
if i forget to mention f sharp in this
context of being open source this is a
hate storm after this
so c sharp vb and f sharp are all open
source you can go ahead and contribute
your language features if they're
approved all the discussions around
which features to add to the language
that's all done in the open you can
participate in the discussion you can
see the ideas behind why a certain
language feature might be valuable to
the language
you can even just help out update the
documentation if you so like to
so with that out of the way
if we just look at a few highlights c
sharp 7's been around for quite a while
now
but one of the
interesting things with with the fact
that this is open source is that they've
been able to add so many features into
the language so i don't want to alienate
anyone
the first feature i want to talk about
is tuples or tuples depending on where
you're from and how you like to
pronounce it we're talking about the
same thing
prior to c sharp seven
we had to work with tuples in a
rather interesting way
we had this type called tuple and this
was a generic type and you access
properties and fields like you do any
normal class
the problem here excuse me is that item
one two and three
they don't have any proper naming so
this was really hard to work with
so as of c sharp seven this is now a
first class citizen in the programming
language so as you'll see here tuples in
c-sharp seven allows you to construct
this grouping of elements
where each of the different
things you put in your tuple
so
fields and you get that you get names
for those fields during compile time and
during the the work that you do in your
program
it's not a part of the actual compiled
version
so why are we talking about this and why
is this such a big change
the fact is that this is kind of one of
those things that was needed to be added
to allow us to easily work with pattern
matching which was introduced in c sharp
eight
together with tuples we also got
something called deconstruction which is
a way to take an object and pull that
apart into different types of variables
and different types of pieces and make
it look like a tuple it's sort of
they're totally different things but
they were used together
and hopefully you'll understand why in
just a second
if i have a class let's say that the
class exposes
a name and an age property and i simply
just add this method to this class
what this now allows me to do
is to deconstruct this object
look at this here i have an instance of
a person and i just
dereference that or reference that into
something that looks like a tuple
what happens here is that this instance
is deconstructed into two local
variables
a name and an h variable the compiler
will make sure that it calls the
deconstruct method
to do this it's a handy feature
but used on its own like this here
doesn't make much sense but if we keep
this in mind this is one of those
fundamental things that we need to
understand when we start looking at
other new features as well
tuples and deconstructions are often
used together as you'll see here if i
have a tuple here that i defined in line
it contains the variable or the value 10
and 20 that is then deconstructed into
two fields that will exist on this local
variable
might look very weird but this is
kind of a new way of building things in
c sharp seven
but again you wouldn't write this just
out of the way like this here
a better example
is if you have an instance of coordinate
you then deconstruct that into something
similar
right all this is capable by introducing
a method called deconstruct and you can
add this on any type of object
and what's interesting is that
we're going to talk about something
called record types which is a new way
of creating reference types in c sharp
this is added automatically on that
so
if we
skip c sharp 7 and and there's a lot
more attitude language as well
but now we're going to be talking about
c sharp 8 and beyond
because this is where things quiet
changed a little bit more drastically
there's a lot more changes in the
language
and you'll see that if i'm just going to
list out a whole bunch of different
language features
i'm not oops sorry i'm not going to be
able to go through all of these here but
just to give you an idea of the amount
of language features that was added in
the language
got something called read only members
default interface implementations those
pattern matching enhancements and why
i'm saying enhancements here is because
the language designers added a first
version of pattern matching in c sharp
seven but at that point it didn't make
much sense to use it
it's actually not up until i would say
now that i see this used quite heavily
in uc r projects
because something called using
declarations static local functions and
then another really big thing called
nullable reference types
changes the way that we look at nulls
and we'll go get into that as well
the highlighted portions the one that
i've bolded out here that's what we're
going to be looking at a little bit more
in detail
we also got something called
asynchronous streams which is a way for
us to consume data that's streamed into
an application
async disposable ranges analysis and
some null um handling as well
if we want to use this in an old project
we can't simply tell the compiler that
now i want to be using c sharp 8 or c
sharp 9.
what they also made sure here is that
it changed the way that they look at
deploying the language versions
so to use c-sharp 8 you need to use
visual studio 2019 or later
together with dot-net core 3.0
c-sharp 9 requires nine requires.net
five c sharp ten requires.net six
each version of dot net would have a
corresponding c sharp version
this is because they want to be able to
do runtime changes for the language as
well that means that they can do even
further or bigger changes to the
language
that is also tied into changes in the
run time
in the past that was a little bit more
difficult because the teams were i
believe more separated in the
organization but now that everything's
open source they can just help each
other out
that's great
so if you want to use the latest and
greatest always use the latest visual
studio
obviously that's not always going to be
working in new projects some of the
language features are also available to
use on older frameworks but you have to
that we if we are download in winforms
or wpf
we might not be able to just jump on net
core right we couldn't do that so they
had to also introduce
project templates for dotnet core for
wpf as well as winforms
so you can use this across all the
different types of applications
all right
one language feature that is kind of
this i don't know if this is an english
expression but you have like a water
divider so you have one portion of the
water on this side that loves it and
then the other people on the other hand
hates it
i think most people don't like this
but that's just
that's just me
this here is known as default interface
implementations
from a perspective of a library
developer imagine that i want to update
my package i want to deploy that out to
my millions of users if i'm lucky enough
to have that many people using my
project that's great
but one of the drawbacks with that is
that i don't want to break anyone's code
by updating an interface i require
everyone to implement all my new members
or all my new methods
with this here i've now added an
implementation to my
interface
looks like a normal class except there's
no instance of the class
what this now does is that it allows me
to deploy a default implementation this
doesn't do anything
and the problem with this approach is
that
if i just download the new version of
this this interface or the new package
that contains the interface
there's no warning that i haven't
implemented this because there's already
an implementation provided by the the
library developer
that's something to keep in mind if you
ever have to use this
so basically you can have method bodies
on your methods on your interfaces
now this
dot requires.net core 3.0
so what happens if i have a net standard
library so we're not going to be talking
about the differences between framework
standard and all of that because that's
a whole session on its own
but what happens if this lives in a
shared library that's compiled to
multiple targets that would be a little
bit problematic
we do get a little bit of help here i'm
going to zoom in here it's going to tell
me that the target runtime that i'm not
that i'm currently building for doesn't
support this particular language feature
so the compiler is trying to be smart
enough to tell me that you're now using
a feature for one of the targets but it
doesn't work so you have to do something
else this is where you end up having a
lot of if devs and
a lot of other ugly code
anyways it's a nice addition to library
authors
now
i did say that i want to talk about one
really interesting feature of c sharp
and that's nullable reference types
how many here have had a null reference
exception
no one
everyone
perfect
who loves them
no one loves no reference exceptions
i've heard this many times but someone
said that
null reference exceptions is one of
those things that costed the world
the most in terms of crashes in
applications
right
and the problem with null reference
exceptions is that
we really don't know that they're gonna
occur right we have to guard against
them everywhere
and the code becomes hard to read and
hard to understand
that's why they introduce something
called nullable reference types which is
the naming here is a little bit
confusing because reference types have
always been nullable you've always been
able to set a reference type to null so
what they've actually done is that
they've introduced all reference types
are not null
and i'll show you that in just a second
we've all had this happened in different
types of applications
and we all love it
so how do we approach this in a
different way to avoid all of these
different types of crashes
well we can't get rid of nulls in the
language because it's been there forever
and that would be quite a breaking
change
but if we take one step backwards what's
the problem with nullability
one of the biggest issues is that we
have to add null checks everywhere in
places where nulls might not even be a
problem
we have to add it everywhere and all of
a sudden the code becomes really hard to
maintain
and we want to add as little code as
possible to have the biggest impact
and then it's kind of ambiguous what
does it mean to return null from a
method
if i return null from a method that
looks for an object
was the object not found was there a
problem did i catch an exception and
just returned null or
what's the
purpose there are many architectural
architecturally
ways to solve this a default object
would be better that tells you the
intent
if you have a method that explicitly
determines that this may return null if
this does something
that's great but we don't want to name
our methods
based on what they may or may not return
in terms of nullability that is
a slightly different type of problem
with nullability is that it encourages
mutability
it encourages us to change objects
and in multi-threaded applications
that's going to be an issue we want to
ensure that objects are immutable
so we are never changing anything once
we've created an instance if you want to
change a field or a property you create
a new instance that way you don't
interfere with any other threads working
on that
that data
because it could end up in cases where
you have partial data that's being
managed across different threads
so that's no good
so an example of a problem or kind of an
ugly piece of code here in this case
here i have an instance of a classical
person i have to check if that's null i
have to check if the address is null and
then check if the street name is not
null we can simplify this by saying
is this null conditional operator to say
well if the address is not null go ahead
and get the or sorry if the person is
not going to get the address and so
forth it's still not very nice
it would be better to assume that person
in this case would never be null here
i should be able to trust that
if i'm in a portion of the code where i
need to access the street name of the
address there should be an instance
otherwise maybe the compiler can be
smart enough to indicate that this could
be potentially null based on other types
or other things that have happened in
the code
so that's where it cut where null state
static analysis comes into play where
this very handy thing called nullable or
nullable context is going to solve all
our problems
if i add this piece a piece of code
inside my
namespace or inside my class or inside
my method this turns on nullable
reference types i can also do this on
the project level which i'll show in a
second here
what this now does is that it changes
the way the compiler looks at my
reference types
everything is now assumed to be
non-annulable
this means in this case here we're going
to get a warning
here we have a warning telling us well
string here is not null so you shouldn't
set this to null
still just warnings right
but then it's getting smarter here
since it knows that i've set this to
null
somewhere else it also knows that it may
be null here
so in this case it would be appropriate
to perform an i'll check
so how about we take a look at a
sample application
if i can exit my powerpoint
phone size is good enough in the back
perfect this here is a dot net six
application this works with the dot net
five as well and
and dot net core 3.0
so i've gone into the project file
i can also do this from the project
settings
if i want to do that
and i'm going to add this
thing here
called nullable enable
now before i save this
um
just notice there's there's nothing this
is just a normal program it has two
classes there's no warnings there's no
nothing i have a person class
has a reference type on it called
details has two strings called first
name and last name
now when i save this here
it's going to change
kind of how the compiler looks at my
reference types
hopefully
look at that worked
now we've got these squigglies here
under details under first name under
last name
of course this is just warnings so if i
bring up my warnings here at the bottom
it's going to tell me
that details here let's see if i can
zoom in
it may be null because you haven't set
this in the constructor
that's good to know
we all know that everyone reads all the
warnings
am i right
so what i can do
i can be a little bit
i can say treat
warnings as errors
true i think it's the default or it's
what i set this to now when i compile
this
hopefully everything's going to blow up
this build failed
now it looks as these warnings as errors
instead and i can't compile the code
unless i fix these null reference
potentially in all reference exceptions
of course that's kind of a big change to
do to a larger project just go ahead and
enable normal reference types and treat
warnings as errors and everyone's going
to hate you
so don't do that what you can do is that
you can enable this for
proportions of the code
so let's do nullable
disable
and now it's only enabled well it's
enabled for everything else but you get
the idea right i can use this compiler
directly to turn it on and off so i
could refactor portions of my code
so to solve these
potential null reference exceptions
you'd have to introduce a constructor
so let's do this on the person instead
i have to introduce a constructor
now the warning disappeared from the
properties because they shouldn't be the
ones that are in charge of setting the
values the constructor should be the one
in charge of setting the values
now telling saying well you're not
setting these properties
and the problem with this approach here
is that i'm now changing the contract to
anyone that's using
first name i can't talk and write at the
same time
i've now changed the contract
of
last name
oh come on
if you've used the latest version of
visual studio you get kind of used to
the the new type of intellisense where
it just predicts everything i just press
tab and just knows exactly what i want
to write i just auto-generate all my
code
right so now we don't have any warnings
anymore
that's great but everyone that's using
this class now has to change how they're
creating an instance
that's a little bit problematic
i do believe that the null reference
exception wouldn't have occurred in this
place here so there's no use in kind of
guarding against nulls here this here is
an old guard
sort of unless someone actually sends
first name and last name as nulls
because it's still allowed to do so
actually let me show you
what this looks like
if i create a new
instance
for details
go to new details
i have to pass first name and last name
right
if i pass null here it's going to give
me a warning telling you that you
shouldn't do this
you're not allowed to use null here but
i can promise that this isn't null
now all of a sudden
i trick the compiler because i know
better
this is not where you should use this
bang operator it's not the best place to
put it but it just shows you that the
compiler
tries to help you but it's not always
going to solve everything for you
so instead of changing the contract of
this details instead what we can do is
that we can go to the root of the
problem and we can say that well i do in
fact want to allow these to be null and
this is where the nullable reference
types come into play
i can now declare that my string here is
allowed to be null by adding a question
mark
that's like you've done with nullable
value types in the past
i can go one step further just to make
sure that this is now using the best
practices i can declare that you're no
longer once you've set this to a value
you're not allowed to change it
this is a feature from c sharp 9 called
the init only auto property
so if i set this to end it here i'm only
allowed to set this once in the object
initializer
and then you can't change it anymore
unless you create a new instance
still have a problem here
it's telling me that details could
potentially be null and i don't want to
change the contract here either so i'm
going to allow this to be null as well
now this is the first i would say
and the biggest problem with nullable
reference types is that you're going to
end up with question marks everywhere
and again it's going to make
maybe it's hard to understand the intent
the idea isn't to end up with question
marks all over the place it's a good way
to refactor portions of the code until
you're actually at a place where you
have a better architecture
but now i can start looking for the
places
where this might actually cause an issue
as you see here it's giving me a an
error here telling me that you're
accessing details here and i know for a
fact that this could be potentially null
right so here i'd need to do a null
guard
right
there's other types of doing all guards
as well i could say i could use i'm
going to show you a pretty cool trick
here
we'll do argument null reference
exception
throw if null
person dot details
oops sorry
look at what happens with the with the
error at the next line
it disappeared
the compiler is now smart enough to know
that
this thing here
null checks
this
that's why i don't get any warnings or
here or errors here at the bottom
right
that's good so that's one way of
minimizing the places where you have to
do null checks
but the root of the problem wasn't
really in here either
problem is that i i have one method here
that returns null
which isn't really that great so if i
want to change this as well
to return something that's a little bit
more
better i would say can create a new
person
i'll show you another new pretty cool
language feature
so i have details here and i don't it's
a property
let's say that we don't really know what
type this is
i can use the new new target type new
expression
i don't have to specify the type anymore
it just figures that out so if it's a
really complex type that you're
instantiating the compiler can figure it
out for you and you don't have to be
explicit about the type you're creating
you can set first name to flip
and then to return this you can use
yield return person
that's pretty cool
i don't have to create a temporary list
i can use the yield keyword to create an
iterator for me and that just
corresponds with the innumerable of
person that had a very top
now the init only keyword that i added
earlier
i'll show you here i can't just access
the person
details
or first name
i can't change that because it's it's
not allowed it's an init only so you're
not allowed to change it afterwards it's
been created
all right
and if i wanted to actually say that i
can return null from this method here
i'd have to explicitly say everywhere in
my code where i want to allow nulls
right and that's not very pretty i'd
have to add question marks all over the
place but it's better to find those
places that could potentially be causing
those null reference exceptions
and now if i build this hopefully
there's no more problems
and the application hopefully works as
well
right so that's a null reference
exceptions
and
this method here relies on something
called the null state static analysis
there's attributes that you can add to
your methods
to do the same thing
so you could say for instance that i
guarantee that whatever thing you passed
into this method i've null checked that
if i return a certain value
that's exactly what this method here
does
if this doesn't throw an exception it's
not null
you don't obviously have to handle the
exception somewhere else you just move
the problem but at least it's
intentional right
it's all about intent
all right
there we go
and of course once you've gotten to a
place where you've
added all the null checks that you have
on the places where it's necessary where
it could potentially be null
you could treat warnings as errors on
your build server and
anytime someone checks something in that
could potentially be null you'd get a
very nice
slack message from them asking you to
turn it off
it's not always going to find everything
but it's a good way of solving a problem
that they couldn't solve right now which
is removing nulls completely other
programming languages like swift kotlin
they make it hard to use nulls out of
the box they tell you that you shouldn't
you have to explicitly say i want to use
nulls they pretty much do the opposite
of what c sharp did in the past
so let's talk about asynchronous streams
and leave the
nullable reference type for a moment
asynchronous streams is a way for it
kind of
requires you to understand asynchronous
programming a little bit
it's a way for us to stream data so
imagine that i have this portion of this
method call here
there's a few things happening in here
that's a little bit different from what
you might have seen in the past
if you have any synchronous methods
called async that just tells it that
it's capable of retrieving data
asynchronously it doesn't mean that the
entire method is in fact going to run on
a separate thread or going to be faster
than what it could be
it's just a way for you to
enable that capability so to say
this is then coupled with the i async
innumerable
excuse me
that's indicating that this is going to
give you an iterator that's going to
allow you to
asynchronously retrieve strings
so each string is going to be returned
out of this enumerable asynchronously
and obviously this is called read lines
async so that means we're going to read
something from disk
so we indicate that the data will be
streamed
which means that it's just going to read
one file at one line at a time from disk
and then return that
i can use a yield return to do that so i
use yield together with a weight
somewhere in this code here and that's
what performs all the magic
it tells the iterator that there's a new
item to process
now instead of
going through the code in
in powerpoint
i actually improved this code a little
bit
today
which is always a good idea
to do right before you go on stage so
what i did here i increased i introduced
this method here called
get lyrics
the idea here is that i want to get each
line
from this file
one at a time we can just imagine that
this is loaded from somewhere else it
loaded from the web it might be an
expensive database operation so i have
this this fictive delay here of 400
milliseconds
to open the this stream reader
i'm using this using declaration using
declarations was also introduced
quite recently in c-sharp
and what it ensures is that it's going
to be disposed of at the end of the
method call
and it's quite a lot happening in here
since this is asynchronous programming
it's going to
context switches it's going to involve
different threads
the fact that this here closes the
stream to the disk after all of that is
done is pretty amazing
then what i do here is that i i together
with pattern matching i say while there
is a line that i can read
and i'm using this the var pattern here
to say that if this is a string i'm
going to capture this into a local
variable
this here performs a null check it
stores whatever read line async returns
into that local variable which is only
then available inside this context here
and then i have a 400 second milli 400
millisecond delay and then return
so this is cool this is a way to just
read stuff asynchronously or read one
thing at a time how do i then consume
this
you do that
normally when you call
a an asynchronous method
you do something like this right so you
say give me all of whatever this is
returning that's what you normally do
maybe this is hard to read in the back
normally you do that right
but now
you don't do that anymore well you say
instead you say a wait for each
for a line in
get lyrics
right so
kind of change the way that you look at
using the away keyword so what i'm doing
here
the weight keyword in front of a for
each loop means that each line here is
going to be retrieved or each item is
going to be retrieved asynchronously
so if i print this out to the console
hopefully this is going to work
dot net run
look at that
works
i think this is pretty cool and it's
useful in cases where you want to stream
data into an application it doesn't as
with any i innumerable you don't have to
know where it where it's ending right
which is why it's not the best idea to
do two array on innumerables because
they could be infinite amount of
elements being streamed into that
innumerable
there's no ending here like we're doing
yield return how do we know if this
maybe this file here is being fed with
data all the time
so
yeah
the for each loop allows us to iterate
over this data asynchronously
all right
so that's c sharp eight
quite a lot of features i've showed you
a few of them added to c sharp from c
sharp nine as well
one of the biggest features added to c
sharp nine is something called record
types it's one of the
we've been waiting for this for a very
long time
they promised to add something that
looked like record types all the way
back in c-sharp six
but it's been really hard to implement
it's
i don't know why but
then again i'm not a language designer
but
there's a lot of complex
situations
that they had to handle but it's finally
there
we looked at the end only setters
the top level statements i didn't
mention this but
the application
that i had over here
this is a top-level statement there's no
public static void main stuff or
anything like that
this is just a normal console
application with just a few lines of
code this actually generates all of that
behind the scenes but it makes it easier
to just focus on the code
maybe not for
experienced developers but especially
when you're learning about c-sharp
or building minimal apis it's nice to
just be able to
deploy like a single file
and have all the logic in one place
unless it's a lot of logic that is
c sharp nine also came with a lot of
changes to pattern matching as well
which we're going to spend a bit of time
talking about in just a moment
and then there's a bunch of other things
as well
it's kind of
a lot of features to add to a
programming language just in one
iteration of it if we compare this to
other programming languages
i don't want to name it but the one by
oracle
i'm just kidding they actually got a lot
of features as well so they they help
each other out i know microsoft talks a
lot with other language designers from
other teams
like swift and kotlin and java and all
of that
i try to make the best programming
language
so
what i like about c sharp is that each
feature that they add to the language
is in fact
looks and acts very much like a c-sharp
language feature they try to make it so
that if you know c-sharp
you're still going to be comfortable
working with those features
some of it looks a little bit
odd and some of it might look very
unfamiliar but once you get into it it's
it's really nice and pattern matching is
one of those things
the whole idea with pattern matching is
that we can look on an object or the
different traits and attributes and
understand what an object is
and write code that expresses what we're
looking for
i might be looking for a particular
shape of an object i might be looking
for different
let's say colors or if it's an edible
fruit or whatever
might be very different things that i'm
looking for i might be looking for very
particular things in a large segment of
data for instance let's say that i'm
looking at the last 128 bytes in a byte
array to validate a signature that needs
to be a very specific set of numbers i
could for instance use pattern matching
for that
hopefully in c sharp 11 when they're
adding list patterns
this isn't really a new concept the idea
of looking at the type and just matching
ifs and else or you know
or just looking at different attributes
on a type it's been possible for a very
long time
just as i mentioned earlier it's just a
way a different way of expressing the
intent using less characters less code
that's more understandable
in this case here i get the type i
compare the type to what i'm looking for
then i'm looking at a property and then
i'm doing something with that particular
object
in c sharp 7 they introduced a first
version of pattern matching that allowed
us to look a little bit differently
at the same
type of code but express this in a
little bit of a different manner
now we can use something called a switch
with the object and instead construct
an expression that says well in the case
of this being an apple when the color is
green then i want to go into this
this um
this case block
and what's interesting here is that it's
the correct type i don't have to cast it
into any particular type once i'm inside
this here and the compiler
evaluated this pattern and it knows what
type it is i don't have to do anything
right
and then what was introduced
is something called a switch expression
which is a different way of of working
with objects in constructing these types
of pattern matches
so
here we have the input
and this is the object that i want to
construct patterns for
all right and then i can fill this
switch block here or this switch body
this is known as a switch expression
with all my different expressions
so here
i could say that i based on the fruit
what this is
if it matches an apple then this is
going to be returned so everything on
the right hand side of the expression
just like an expression-bodied member is
what's going to be returned it doesn't
necessarily have to be a string it could
be anything
and you could use this in very
interesting situations you could for
instance say give me the result of this
operation if it's a failed result do
this if it's a successful result do this
that's a very basic way of looking at
pattern matching
so with pattern matching in c sharp
there's quite a lot of patterns and
there this is one of the things that i
think is going to be
evolved much further over the years
so we see that with the new versions of
c-sharp they're adding even more
patterns to allow us to express things
that might have been hard to do before
we just saw the type pattern
there's a way for us to look at a tuple
and compare different positions in the
tuple to different values there's a
property pattern there's a
there's something called a tuple pattern
that allows you to match exactly what a
tuple is
and we're going to look at a few of
these in just a moment
it's a relational pattern to allow you
to compare different values
you can do and or and parenthesize
patterns you can negate patterns and you
can introduce something called recursive
patterns
so let's take a look at a few of these
here
i'm going to create a new project
just a console application
you can call it console app one
i'm going to use dotnet 6
the lts version
and this here is the new top level
statement that you'd get if you just
create a new
application
and i need to bring in a file
alright so this here is a test result
imagine this is a test result for when
you've been to university or done some
courses and you've written a test
so maybe if you're like me you have to
do the tests a couple of times before
you succeed
especially if it's math it's not my
strongest subject so we have a public
property called number of tests a
boolean if it's valid uh when this was
tested on and i've also introduced a
deconstruct method that allows us to
deconstruct this into something that's
just represents this object in a
different manner right
so i can say how many days since the
test and if it's still valid
this doesn't have to be in correlation
to the properties that you have this
could be as you see here i'm computing
how long it was since i did the test
based on the property value and the date
then i have a few subclasses
if it's a positive or a negative test
or it should be passed or failed maybe
see i've used this quite a lot and just
now i realize the naming is not the best
beauty of software development so let's
now say that i want to use this here
i have my test
test result
let's call it test result and let's
create a new positive result
now
i can use patterns in not only with the
switch expressions i keep using with
switches or if else else ifs as well so
i could say that if the test result
test result if i can spell is
positive
this is going to do quite a few things
i feel two things
one it's going to ensure that it's an
instance of an object
it's actually checking if it's set to a
value and then also making sure that the
type is correct
if i if i want to say if it's if it's
not null i can do that as well
that would match on any different types
it would match on if it's negative as
well
now if i want to make it a little bit
more interesting maybe i want to say
that well if this is a positive test
result
and
you only had to do this test within a
certain amount of tries
then
you're a gold star student so how would
i express that well i can use a
recursive pattern which is a way for me
to apply an additional pattern that is
also evaluated
so first we check if it's positive
and then i can use something called a
property pattern to say well if the
numbers number
of tests
is less than or equal to five then
you're awesome
and if it's more than
or equal to two you're also awesome
right so i can kind of express myself
in ways that might have been a little
bit difficult before
and what's pretty cool here is that
inside the scope here
i think i can capture this as a result
variable
and i can now use this here
as the proper type
if i can zoom in here you'll see that it
says that this is a positive test result
so it was captured into the if statement
as the correct type of which it was
matched to be
right
so there's quite a things quite quite a
few things happening in here and what i
did here was a few things i did a
relational pattern i have a property
here that could be it's an integer and
then i'm saying this can be between two
values
so i used an and here to say that it has
to be more than
five unless or more than two less than
five sorry
we could also use this together with the
switch expression
to for instance
dictate the outcome of the test
so based on the test result
i
start this switch expression
i can use a discard
just do this i can use a discard here to
say that
for everything
that's not matched above so just like a
normal switch okay you have to add the
the most granular ones at the top so you
have to say
you can't add the default case at the
top because then it won't match anything
else
so for
where the discard here is called this
called a discard keyword if you use that
that's kind of the default case it
captures everything if it's null if it's
whatever if you don't want to capture
null you say not null
right
and then you can say
if it is null do this
but the same would be to say
discard make sense
now
i can apply a few different patterns
here first i could do the same thing we
did at the top so say that i can use a
type pattern to say if it's positive
i'll actually
do not available on this one
so for
for all the positive tests i'm just
going to return the string positive and
if it's a positive test let's say
let's use the same pattern we have at
the at the top
positive come on
number of tests
is above five
right
so i can add a lot of different test
cases and i can add a lot of different
patterns in here and use different
patterns available in c sharp
what's interesting is that if i remove
this here
that's also valid
so i don't have to check the type
if i don't want to i could say that for
all different tests
if it's it's valid
for example if it's a valid
passed or failed test right or negative
or positive
one thing you should avoid doing
is negating these types of patterns
you can but you shouldn't
just as with any code that you write
just be cautious and this here is
interesting because what it's doing
it might not be doing what you want do
you think this is going to match if it's
null
maybe
this here the property pattern will
ensure that it has an instance
and then if that instance has a property
of
of called its valley that is true
then i negate that entire expression so
if there's not an instance this is true
if there is an instance and if its valid
is false
it becomes really hard to understand
exactly what your intent is here
yes exactly what
try to think about the other developers
that come after you that have to
maintain the code
right
not null make sense using not in other
places
might be
be cautious with that
i also mentioned that you can use the
positional pattern to
leverage the deconstruct method so i
could say that
based on how this is deconstructed so if
you go into the test result i know that
i have two out parameters here
and based on what we talked about
earlier i can take an object and i can
deconstruct that into a different
representation
based on this here it returns an integer
and a boolean
so what i can do with this here is that
i have built in support
that this here can deconstruct the
object for me
if i say that i want to use a positional
pattern
i can fill this with exactly the number
of
of parameters that's output or
deconstructed out of that
so where this makes a little bit more
sense is if we named parameters is valid
is valid
and intellisense doesn't help at all
here
so what this lets me do is that i could
deconstruct the object and if it can be
deconstructed into something that
generates true
that's more than 10 days old or 10 days
ago
then i want to evaluate that expression
so hopefully this just shows you a few
examples of examples of how powerful
pattern matching can be in the way that
you can express yourself in different
ways
there's many different patterns and many
different ways to do this
but
yes it is obvious getting your code if
you're not using it properly
and i'm kind of intentionally
showing you ways to not do this because
you should be really cautious when you
do this it might be very
easy for you to understand when you
write this code
personally
this approach is fine
if you're very explicit about what
you're talking about in this case here
if i didn't have the name parameter and
just said over 10 and true how would i
know what that is i don't want to
force anyone to go in to look at a
deconstruct method that might live on a
base class in a nuget package that i
know that i don't own
you know so that might feel really hard
so in this case here i would be if you
have to use the deconstruct
i would say
do something like this here instead
use it together with the the name
parameters so it makes sense exactly
what your intent is
okay
so we have
let's see here
let's um let's talk about record types
about 10 minutes left
so i want to show you what record types
are all about
record types is a new type of reference
type that was introduced in c sharp
it all starts with the keyword record
you can have a record class
you can have a record struct
and that's just because it makes sense
to
allow you to explicitly define that
and it does give you a little bit of
code out of the box as well if you don't
specify anything and you just say record
that's going to be a record class
so if we say we have a record called
person
this here is now
a record declaration
and it comes with something called a
positional constructor or primary
constructor
where i can say that this person has a
first name
and it has a last name
and now what happened behind the scenes
here is that this here generated a whole
bunch of code for us
code that should make it easier for us
to work with reference types
if i create a new
sorry
if i create a new person
new person
i have to
specify the the first name and last name
berg
and it's immutable by default so i
couldn't say that i want to change any
of the properties on this here
first name
i couldn't do that
because it's an init only property
if i do want to get
a new person within you with a new name
let's say that i want to get a person
two
that's the second person
person
with
first name
first
intellisense doesn't work very well with
top-level statements i'm sorry
actually let's do yeah let's do take my
wife's name
so now what happened here is that i've
copied the entire instance
this with expression
was also introduced with c sharp nine
and allows you to copy pretty much
everything you can copy an anonymous
type you can copy a tuple you can copy
your your
reference types and you can do this with
the
the record it allows you to change the
values
of the properties that you want to
change
but what happens if we have a reference
type on that
would you imagine that it copies the
entire reference type or does it only
copy the reference itself
it doesn't perform a deep copy i'm sorry
so if we have for instance an
innumerable
of string
phone
numbers
if i have this here it would copy
the reference it wouldn't copy all the
elements in the list of phone numbers
unless
this also was a record
but you can experiment with that
yourself
so
what's interesting here is that if i
compare
my my first person to my second person
obviously if i run this here
and set the correct project as a startup
project
oh it was perfect it's going to say
false
because they're not the same
makes sense but if i copy this person
and set the the name to
the same name as i have and i run this
again
when you compare to reference types
normally it returns false because it's
different references
but in this case here with record types
you get value-based equality which means
that it's going to compare each
properties it overloads the equality
operator and make sure that it compares
all the properties that are available on
those different types
so to show you exactly what you get from
a record
i'm going to copy this here there's
multiple ways to do this
i've already pasted this in here
so i'm at sharplab.io which is a way for
you to write c sharp code and you can
decompile that and look at what the code
generates
would be awesome if i could do a white
team here but
i don't think i can do that oh perfect
there we go
so let's scroll down here
we have
we have a class called person
which implements iequatable
it has two
private read-only fields it has an
equality contract it has two properties
it has the constructor it overrides two
string
there's a lot of code in here that's
generated by just introducing that
record keyword
and where it gets pretty interesting is
when it overwrites the equals method
here from the i equality operator
it checks
that the first name for the backing
field is equal to the other person's
backing field so this is in fact doing
true value based equality
and you also get this deconstruct method
out of the box you can use these with
the patterns that you might have
introduced earlier
so honestly the record types are really
powerful the only place where you cannot
use them is with entity framework
because entity framework relies on
references
and since this is doing value-based
equality that won't work but for
everywhere else where you have a data
container or like a
a domain object that represents some
data or you might not want your entity
to flow through the application you
might map that to a record instead
and you get a lot of my things nice
things out of the box
all right
so a few minutes left let's talk about c
sharp 10 and 11.
so c sharp 10 also introduced the record
struct so you can do get the same type
of of generated code structs are
value-based
use value based on quality but
you get all the other nice things
that record provides
some other nice improvements like global
using the directive so you could say at
one place in the application i want to
be able to use this namespace and that
just works throughout the entire
application so you don't have to have
the using at the top of each file
which is a nice addition
you can see something called a file
scope namespace declaration so instead
of having to
having to wrap your entire
let's
go in here
instead instead of having to wrap your
entire file in a namespace you could say
namespace
namespace ndc
and this entire file would then be a
part of the ndc namespace
and that didn't work because i had that
in a top level statement
they've done some changes to property
patterns
and dumps done some improvements to
lambda expressions
it's quite a quite a nice set of
features as well in c sharp 10 not as
big as in c sharp 8 and 9 but it's still
a it's a nice set of features
they're looking at or they have added
the
static
sorry static abstract members in
interfaces if that's something that you
want to use this is for very specific
use cases where you might have
custom math implementations and so forth
right
also introduced constant interpolated
strings so you don't have to
you can use that with string
interpolation as well
another cool feature is inferred type
of the lambda so in c sharp nine you had
to explicitly declare which type of func
that you were using
but now with c sharp 10 you don't have
to do that
it's now the the using the
natural type of the lambda
and with the lambda improvements and i
don't know if you've seen the top level
statements but they've also made
a whole lot of improvements to the fact
that you can use
attributes in your lambdas so you could
for instance write a
really nice this here
is in fact inside a top level statement
if i run this
it's going to
boot up a
asp.net web application it's a little
bit of code at the top as well but
basically i can write an entire asp.net
core mvc application in just a few lines
of code
right so in about 35 seconds let's see
what's next in c sharp
that's not a lot
in fact i
i didn't want to spend too much time
talking about c sharp 11 because
based on experience
in six months
none of this is going to be in the
language
unfortunately they're doing a lot of
more patterns they're they want to add
list patterns and slice patterns and
span patterns we didn't talk about spans
and slices and ranges and all of that
but for pattern matching that's going to
be a nice addition as well
name of parameter is one thing they want
to add and the big thing is they want to
cache the delegates for static method
groups so if you have lambdas that just
points to or a func that points to one a
method in your application and you have
that in a in a loop
it's going to cache that method instead
of having to use an additional
allocation for each iteration
i think any new required properties
keyword so that you're required to
specify the property or set that
property when you create an instance of
the object
something called raw string literals
static members and interfaces and i just
showed you a snippet of that
they also want to
this is an interesting change they want
to add something called utf-8 string
literals
so i can take my name here and i can
just assign that to a span of byte and
this would generate a byte array
of utf-8 bytes
which is nice if you pass data across
the wire quite a lot
so depending on the type of application
you're building this is going to be a
nice addition
and another one is generic attributes so
you could say that you have an attribute
that is a generic type you haven't been
able to do this in the past you had to
rely on the type off and it was quite
ugly
so finally we're getting that
and for those of you that were hoping
for something called parameter null
checking
unfortunately the community voted that
down after they implemented the feature
basically they wanted to allow you to do
bang bang which is the double
exclamation marks so for any parameter
that you accept to a method you add bang
bang and then it automatically null
check that and if it was knowledge
through an exception
and that's another thing 50 probably
didn't want that
but so they removed that all kudos to
microsoft that's quite amazing
so if you want to learn more about c
sharp and all the language features in a
little bit more slow pace i have a lot
of courses on pluralsight i just
released a course on a lot of language
features so if you have seven hours to
spare
go ahead and have a look at that
so thank you so much for for letting me
come here to talk today it's been a
pleasure
thank you
you